There are many reasons that a controller
might want to write policy, to change the
state and the network switches, including maintenance, unexpected
failure, and traffic engineering. Any of these network
tasks involve or require updating state in the
network switches, and when that state transition happens,
we want to make sure that forwarding remains
correct and consistent. In particular, we would like
to maintain the following in variance: there shouldn't be any
forwarding loops and there shouldn't be any black holes whereby
a router or switch receives a packet and doesn't know
what to do with it. There also shouldn't be cases
where traffic is going where it shouldn't be allowed to
go because of the network being in an inconsistent state.
Let's now consider an example of what might happen when
policies are written to the network, if they're written in
an inconsistent fashion. Let's consider a case where
we have a network that is performing shortest routing
to some destination. And the link weights are
as at shown here in the figure. Traffic in
the network would flow along a path shown
in green. Let's suppose now that an operator wants
to change the network state to shift traffic off of this link. He could do so by
updating the link weight. In doing so, the new shortest path from this top
router would be as follows. But, what if the state in the top switch
occurred before the state in the bottom switch could be updated? In this case,
we would have a potential forwarding loop.
Traffic would proceed to the bottom switch.
But the bottom switch would still have the
old network state, and would continue to forward traffic
to the top switch, resulting in a forwarding loop.
If rules are installed along a path out of
order, packets may reach a switch before the
new rules do. So, in this type of model
we would have to think about all possible packet
and event orderings to ensure that consistent behavior resulted.
So we need atomic updates of the entire
configuration. The solution to this problem is to use
a two phase commit so that packets are either
subjected to the old configuration on all switches, or
to the new configuration on all switches. But
packets aren't subjected to the new policy on some
switches and the old policy on others. The idea
is to tag the packet on ingress so that
the switches maintain copies of both P1 and P2 for some time. When all
switches have received rules corresponding to the
new policy, then incoming packets can be tagged
with P2. After some time, when we're sure that no more packets with P1
are being forwarded through the network, we
can only then remove the rules corresponding to
policy P1. Now, the naive version of
two-phase commit, requires doing this on all
switches at once. Which essentially doubles the
rule space requirements, since we have to store
the rules for both P1 and P2. We can limit the scope of the two phase commit by
only applying this mechanism on switches that involve the affected portions of
the traffic, or the affected portions of the topology.